good morning John I'm in Anaheim right
now look it's Anaheim out there it looks
mostly just white but I promise that's
the Anaheim Convention Center I'm here
planning for VidCon because apparently I
didn't have enough to do with Lizzy
benett Diaries and 2D glasses and sow
and crash course and dftba Records
starting now we're going to travel
around this place where we're having
VidCon in June by screaming
ah this is the lobby of the Hilton quite
nice ah and here we are in the main
lobby where we will be having our
registration desks and people will be
walking in through those doors and it
will be vard ah and now we are in the
expo hall which is a truly gigantic room
and it's off limits to me in here
so oh my God it's the arena wow this is
where we will be having our main stage
of vids the stage will be here nobody
will be sitting in those seats up there
they will all be sitting back here and
of course on the floor there will be
floor seating and that's how the main
stage will be happening which is a
freaking
Arena now we're back at the convention
center going up to the second floor ah
this is a/4 mile long building and we
have the whole second and third floors
lot of space and we're filling it all up
everybody wants to do something it's
pretty cool ah this is the freaking
awesome building I it's just nice and
spacious and Airy and it's actually like
there's light and it's not in a basement
which is what we had last year and my
cell phone works which it's just it's a
it's a lot
better and now we're on this big outdoor
awesome deck on the third floor that's
Disney back there right now in this
building all the people I just freaked
out are dentists uh so that's not the
most exciting conference in the world
though I did see that there is a talk on
dentistry's role in biot terrorism
events which yay previous years of
VidCon it's always felt like there it's
really easy to get in front of people if
people already know who you are but if
you're a talented person and you haven't
got your name out there yet it's harder
and so we're trying to make that easier
this year with a few different things
also other opportunities that I wanted
people to know about including bcon is
partnering with celebrate the web for a
web series pilot contest and if you win
there are a lot of very cool prizes the
deadline for that is very soon
information in the description for
designers you can potentially design the
shirt that everyone will be wearing at
this year's VidCon literally and if your
design is selected you will win a free
looky camera pretty cool we've also been
asking a bunch of VidCon related
questions at Vu you can go there now and
answer those questions and potentially
something cool might happen if we
actually take one of your suggestions
King of the web is working with us to
Crown a bunch of various VidCon Kings
and music and gaming and vlogging and
other categories pretty sure that comes
with a free ticket to VidCon as well as
like a bunch of cash so we'll be posting
more information about that at
vidcon.com soon musicians you can apply
for our Open Mic room where people who
are a little bit less well known will be
able to play in front of VidCon
attendees also at this year's VidCon
will be raising money for the project
for awesome and the foundation to
decrease World suck through a book drive
and a charity auction so bring books if
you're coming to VidCon also I'm really
excited there's a there's a thing that
we're doing where we basically unlock
achievements if you do certain things at
VidCon you get ribbons to put on your
badge the ribbons will show up at
certain events they'll be given to
people who are curious or who are
awesome or creative or costumed also
speaking of costumes we will be having
an online video costume contest this
year and the winners of that will get to
come up on stage I'm sorry of course to
everyone who can't come this has been an
exhausting as well as an exciting trip
so now I am going
home and I almost forgot you should go
to youtube.com/ crashcourse next week on
Wednesday where we will be answering
your questions and giving you some
behind the scenes look at how crash
course
[Laughter]
Works John I'll see you on Tuesday